dr mark khan the dean of the aquarium
school of medicine at unlv dr as we
mentioned there will be quite a
significant increase in temperature what
can just a mere 10 degrees do well
obviously it depends on where you start
right but i think what we worry about as
we approach triple digits is heat
exposure and also you know heat stroke
which is even more concerning i think
you know it's really important for
people to recognize that the heat here
is significant
so not only do they have to worry about
those things but our pavements get
really hot as well so people can get
second and even third degree burns just
from pavement burns wow i mean we've
heard of that for the animals but you're
talking individuals as well that's right
so i think especially people who are
impaired for some reason so i know that
there are some festivities this weekend
so remember wear shoes really important
yes it is that seems so simple and yet
we are in las vegas after all right all
right you bring up heat exhaustion heat
stroke what are some of those symptoms
you know so i think one of the first
things that we see
is people
starting to feel confused lightheaded
and people even though we don't sweat a
lot in las vegas because of our low
humidity people who aren't sweating and
those sorts of things are concerning if
you're outside and really haven't had to
pee
in several hours that's a pretty good
indication that you're reaching
dehydration so really important
especially with triple digits to have
water with you and to make sure that
you're well hydrated okay at one point
would you seek medical care well medical
care occurs when you actually feel like
you're going to pass out or actually do
pass out i think you know for
mild dehydration get in the shade
get into a cool place drink plenty of
water really important all right and
last question who is most at risk so
people that are most at risk are
obviously people who can't get into a
cool space or don't have access to water
so those are some of our elderly people
but it also occurs when folks are
impaired with things like alcohol and
drugs so really really important to
watch the heat and start to watch the
heat from this point forward this summer
okay thank you so much for coming in dr
khan we greatly appreciate your time